as you probably see this is a little bit
of like an infomercial on this seminar
and in practical mean that we are
covering a lot of things very quickly
and the idea really today is to tell you
that there's going to be a whole seminar
in the next few weeks and that each one
of those things are going to be taken in
great detail so don't worry so much
about this today and in many different
ways
my my role today is to make you really
interested in autism spectrum disorders
that's that's why I'm here so that we
can see you again in the next weeks and
as as dr. Volkow mentioned before when
Leo Kanner
described this condition this is he was
already a very very experienced child
psychiatrist he had written in the first
textbook on child psychiatry and in yet
those eleven children whom he saw and
reported about in 1943 really caught his
imagination and they caught his
imagination because of this thing that
he thought was very special that they
had been born with an inability to
relate Devadas they said they didn't
seem to be tremendously interested in
listening to people or engaging with
people in fact they seem to be happiest
when they were by themselves and and so
when we think about what Leo Kanner
describing what is still valid today is
that autism autism can be really
summarized in in in in what another
doctor wrote about in the book dr. Seuss
I hope you know dr. Seuss he mentioned
that there was thing one and thing two
well the thing one and thing two in
autism are exactly the things that are
kind of described in that paper the
thing one is that this condition is
first and foremost a social disability
in whatever area of research that you
look into and whenever you encounter
individuals of autism the thing that
strikes you the most is that all of
those things that come so effortlessly
to to people even young people even even
even even little children who
intuitively understand others and can
read their minds and can feel their
feelings in many different ways this is
what is not there
it does not mean at all that those
individuals cannot do wonderful things
they can but the sense of a of social
intuition an effortless way are feeling
the other end of reading other people's
minds and what's going on in in in their
beings those are the things that are so
difficult to them so this is thing one
autism is first and foremost a social
disability and think too is that this
condition emerges very early on in life
indeed and that's why it's called a
neurodevelopmental disorder and just to
sort of go back to some of the things
that Fred mentioned before when
individuals are born they are born
prompted to to engage others and and so
in many different ways life begins in
this way becomes a platform for
developing an understanding of others
and understanding of the world
now when Leo Kanner described
individuals of autism and in many
different ways division that people
retain for for years and years and years
was that individuals with autism were
extremely isolated we're really not only
happiest by themselves they were by
themselves most of the time and over the
course of the decades we realized that
in fact there is tremendous tremendous a
range in the way that the syndrome is
manifested in autism we we are struck in
fact by how much variability there is a
know areas of functioning there are
individuals who are profoundly
intellectually disabled two individuals
who are brighter that you or others
individuals who don't talk at all
individuals who talk too much
individuals who are so socially isolated
that if you observe them in the school
you probably see them running the
periphery fence of the school all day if
you let them so individuals who cannot
stop coming and engaging you all the
time even though a little awkwardly so
this range of expressions is what
baffles researchers and if you are
somebody who is trying to understand the
causes of this condition it's very hard
to pick up something that describes or
somehow accounts for some kind of a
psychological process and yet what
you're trying to account for is is a
spectrum that is so vastly different in
different people so this is probably one
of the the greatest challenges that we
the field of Neurobiology and genetics
that what we're trying to capture is
something that is is truly very
heterogeneous but it's important to keep
that in mind whether you're doing
research or whether you're working
clinically because most of us when we
are learning about people and becoming a
clinician we tend to become some how to
acquire those models of how individuals
with autism are or any other condition
but I can tell you one thing that in in
this field it really pays to see a lot
of people because otherwise you have a
very narrow view of the manifestation of
this condition and if you visit for
example one of the schools that some of
you will be placed in I've been Haven
the thread was mentioning you're gonna
see a lot of individuals were very very
challenged most of them are
intellectually disabled for some of them
they're there they're still a trapeze or
the insistence in sameness that dr.
Volkman was talking about maybe maybe
something that occupies them all day
long like for example flicking a little
pencil in front of their eyes all day
long two individuals who are occupying
academic positions and very good
universities all over the place and
whose business in life is is
understanding something that is very
circumscribed for example in science so
the manifestations is huge and so in
order for us to get a sense of what this
is all about we have to go back to to
what is social development again dr.
Volker sort of alluded to that but I'm
but babies are typically developing
babies when they are born they are
extraordinarily fragile if a baby is
born and you leave the baby in the hall
and you come back three days later that
baby is not going to survive and so it
makes sense whether sort of God or
nature created us that it would imbue
those babies with with those
predispositions to seek the other
because without the action of the
caregiver that baby is not going to
survive so from the very first hours of
life babies prefer to listen to human
sounds rather than sounds in environment
they prefer to look at people rather
than things and even as they look at
people they prefer to look at at the
more revealing parts of people from the
standpoint of one's intentions and and
how am I feeling and that's the eye
region of the face the eye is in many
different way
are not only the window to the soul they
are also the window to social
neuroscience for us to understand how
people become engaged others and and
follow through with their social life
now I if one were to sort of simplify a
model for autism this is it those very
early emerging in highly conserved
predispositions to orient and engage
with others those things seem to be
either missing or they are civilians
animated individuals of autism
and if you if you truly understand the
thing - of dr. Seuss that this is a
neurodevelopmental disorder then you
have to think about the cascade of
events that is going to follow from that
imagine that very early on as babies are
engaging or engaging with the world they
may be exploring the world there is a
lovely lady who is always there coming
in bringing things to the baby and the
baby wants something in the world and
that lovely person comes in and brings
it in that's mom
now soon enough they um they they they
understand that's why exhausting oneself
when they can look at mom and that
moment in which they can actually try
and get mom to do things for them this
is a very important in a way an
important event in in social development
this is the moment that babies realize
that that lady over there has something
that is invisible but it's critical in
development and that's called attention
and not only that they can that they can
recognize that the lady has intention
they can guide that attention to
whatever they want and so in this world
much prior to the time that the babies
are capable of even uttering their first
word they are able to move the attention
to something you want through for
example a gesture like pointing and they
can say I want that without necessarily
saying the language or using language or
they can point to something in the world
that they want are the mothers pay
attention to simply because they want to
share an experience not only do they can
use that they can also follow the
gestures of mom and of other adults so
in many different ways what those little
building bricks of a social brain are
doing is that they are preferred they
are preparing this plan
form for social engagement and babies
love the caregivers the caregivers fine
babies very cute and is out of this
mutually reinforcing choreography that a
lot that is importance in development
seems to emerge from and from the
standpoint of autism those are the
things that are not working well and if
you imagine that this are the kinds of
behaviors that we expect to see in
typically developing babies well these
are also the kinds of behaviors that
we're looking for when we walk into a
playroom to make a determination as to
whether or not the two-year-old may or
may not have autism those are the skills
that we're looking for because because
social development becomes this this
iterative process in which I become
increasingly more sophisticated so by
the time that I am - I'm already using
language and I'm developing
relationships eventually most typically
developing dividuals will become experts
on people whereas if this process is
derailed very early on what you're going
to have is a cascade of disruptions in
development and what you see is that for
many of our of our folks the individuals
of autism it's not that they're not
learning about the world they are and
sometimes they are learning about the
world in such a sophisticated way but
those things then to be about things
rather than about people so many
different ways they can they can write
wonderful assets maybe about deeper in
biology or astrophysics but the things
that come so easily to you or to anybody
who is who's not affected by the
condition those things that aren't
really important for daily lives for
navigating the demands of everyday life
those things are the most difficult for
them and so we mentioned a little bit
about some of the early disruptions um
if we if we were to come up with a
synonym with another way of calling this
condition I mentioned before it would be
a disorder or social intuition in many
different ways most of the time we are
obsessed about what other people are
thinking about us what they are feeling
about us the judgment that they're
passing so even in a moment like this I
am sort of scanning the room and trying
to get a sense of what are you thinking
and are you thinking that maybe you will
pursue
and and engage in discourse or maybe
you're gonna think all you know this is
not really interesting I I'll try
something else as I am doing that I'm
trying to adjust my style as I speak
with you and trying to keep you engaged
because most of my thoughts right now
have to do with what you're thinking
this is the first thing that goes into
my mind well most of us did that most
most of us are extra ordinarily a hugely
sensitive or being the object of
somebody else's subjectivity well that's
something that doesn't seem to concern
many many individuals of autism and
that's what what really characterizes
condition now I mentioned before that a
lot of individuals with autism are
intellectually very challenged and yet
even for those who are very very
challenged those who have intellectual
disabilities mental retardation their
level of social disability is even
greater so what what truly defines this
condition is the gap that exists between
their cognitive power whether they have
an IQ of 40 140 and their ability to
interactive others that that gap is
something that exists throughout across
the spectrum of conditions now what dr.
VARs mentioned before is really
important for us to keep in mind
particularly if you become a clinician
because the way that autism is
manifested in babies is different than
the way it is manifested with with
preschoolers and so on into adulthood so
many individuals who might have been
very aloof early on become more
passively as well acceptors of other
peoples of other people's approaches and
some might actually become very obsessed
about engaging you and asking you
specific questions and even though they
might do so in a kind of awkward way I
remember in fact the first school for
children of autism that I worked with
and there was this child who who
approached me almost every day and I
have a funny name my name is Amy and he
would come to me and say what's your
name and I would tell him my name and go
away second day of training
would say my name it go away and it took
me a few days until I realized that
there was something wrong going on and
the next time he came to me and he asked
me what's your name I said John and then
he said what's your age and he went on
what happened is that he had a very
rigid way of engaging with others and so
you asked the name and then the age
where do you live you have brothers and
sisters and so forth he asked me my name
I said Amy Amy ain't a name so he
couldn't go on and so I basically got
him stopped in his tracks in them he
couldn't continue so it's that level of
rigidity it's that sense that unless
things are exactly as they are expected
to be in this world then people find a
tremendous difficulty with and and so
together with the issues with social
intuition that issues the flexibility
because individuals with autism with
spectrum disorders are sublimely
sublimely
rigid now just because this is an
introductory class and you wouldn't
expect to leave this room without having
a test and so um here is a test for you
how many of you have seen this classic
cartoon that was published in 1944 Oh
excellent
so and for those of you who have seen it
I don't want to see what other people do
with it okay
so this is a cartoon those created in
1944 by by two psychologists Fritz
Heider and Marion Zimmer and it's about
two triangles in one circle
I don't know if I should add some
sound-effects but oh no
not there so this movie is only about
geometric shapes or is it well if you
show a cartoon like that who are
typically developing adolescents the
kind of thing and the kind of narrative
that you're gonna get is something like
this what happened it was at the larger
triangle which was like a bigger kid or
a bully and he had isolated himself from
everything else until two new kids come
along and the little one was a bit more
shy and scared and the smaller triangle
more like stood out for himself and
protect the little one the big triangle
got jealous of them came out and started
to pick on the smaller triangle the
little triangle got upset and said like
what's up why are you doing this well
this adolescent was on drugs well not
necessarily
basically that adolescent is is
immediately involved by D by the social
story and that disregards entirely the
desert just to meet geometric shapes now
this is a typically develop an equally
bright adolescence of autism and this is
what he said the big triangle word into
the rectangle there were small triangle
encircled the big triangle went out the
shapes bounce off each other the small
circle and inside the rectangle the big
triangle was in the box with the circle
the small triangle in a circle and
around each other a few times up to year
all that this person is talking about is
geometric shapes but he knew I needed
more so he went on to say they were kind
of oscillating around each other maybe
because of a magnetic field now there is
something very special about our
thinking about things and thinking about
people we showed those two individuals
the same and biggest visual display
which is that classic cartoon but one
was thinking about people and the other
one was thinking about geometric shapes
and physics now why this is so important
this is important because this is the
most a challenging situation that
individuals with autism of all levels of
function they have to face every day in
their lives
which is walking into that naturalistic
setting when they are for example
they're in their high school cafeteria
and there are lots and lots of triangles
and circles all around them if they are
thinking about magnetic fields they're
not going to understand the situation so
that kind of obsession that we
Oh feel about the other and what they
are doing and how does and how that
impacts me and what I should do next
those are actually survival things and
in many different ways of survival
things are the things that make it
possible for us to navigate the demands
of everyday life in social life but it
also makes it possible for us to fend
for ourselves and it doesn't happen in
Connecticut but in other parts of the
country if you walk into a school you
will see individuals like that these are
creatures that we need to understand it
they're coming to help us or to hurt us
they are there are those individuals
friends of folks for many of our folks
with autism those are very perilous
situations because they do not they are
not able to in a way read people's
intentions and therefore they don't know
if those individuals are there to maybe
set them up and make them look bad now
there is something about thinking and
seeing individuals with autism are not
obsessed with others they are not
thinking about others when we were
conducting this kind of research we
always ask ourselves the question are
they looking at people because there was
something about looking at and thinking
about if I am if I'm looking at you do
you have a sense that I'm thinking about
you yeah oh good do you have a sense
that I am thinking about you because I'm
staring at you right so the the notion
that looking at and thinking about are
two things that happen together are
things that we all feel in many
different ways very naturally and so we
have to have a way of in a way visualize
the world for people's eyes how do
individuals of autism see the world what
are the things that are important to
them and the things that are not so
important how are they looking at people
who are interacting in many different
ways what we wanted to do is to stand
right behind their eyes and project
ourselves and see what they are seeing
and so in order to do that one thing
that we did is that we created a lab and
in this lab we are able in a very
non-invasive way map what individuals
with autism are seeing and here is a
summary of our lab
in our eye tracking laboratory as images
for the experiments are presented on a
ray of computers and televisions tracked
where the participant is looking the
size of her pupil and the velocity of
our eye movements all of this data are
recorded in video and America form for
analysis the following images show in
slow motion where a bright intelligent
autism is looking while viewing the
movie classic was Afraid of Virginia
Woolf can you see the cross the cross on
the screen points exactly to where the
viewer of autism is looking at any given
moment as can be seen he focuses
primarily on the actors mouth throughout
this and subsequent clips
the person of typical development
focuses primarily on the person's eyes
much of the social cues of intention and
emotion are expressed through a person's
eyes it is very likely that the person
you've autism is getting much less
information importance so so here is a
bit of an experiment to you this is a
scene from the same movie and the white
cross is a typical viewer an adult and
here is a viewer of autism and this is
actually the way that a social
interaction happens it happens very
quickly so see if you can follow that
was that too fast so let's do it in slow
motion see if you can follow that
well this is what happened what happened
is that Richard Burton broke that bottle
and there was a cut in the movie the
typical viewer went straight to the
person's eyes and the viewer of autism
went alongside the eyes and is going to
rest in the person's mouth now do me a
favor
take your hands and uncover the lower
part of this man's face and then the
upper part of this man's face and tell
me where is his emotion of right well
nobody's saying anything so for the lazy
among you it's in the eye so at that
moment in time that individual if autism
basically was focusing on an aspect of
the face that was quite expressionless
in many different ways he missed that
quick cue as to what is the meaning of
that scene now I'm gonna give a whole
talk about about social development in
autism and we're going to go over many
many of those kinds of examples ranging
from a work that we did of adolescents
and adults to work that is that was done
with toddlers to what is being done
these days with newborns and little
babies and you're going to see many of
our colleagues are focusing on aspects
of the social brain calving Palfrey is
going to be talking about in their
imaging the genius of apartment is going
to be talking about it and
electrophysiology but those are the
kinds of things that have been puzzling
us for quite some time and those things
are not subtle at all for example in
this scene here what is the most
important thing that is happening it's
okay for you to say it's medical well
there is a kiss and what and where is
that adult with autism looking at that
particular moment in time well he's
looking at this light switch that is on
this side so obviously those are the
kinds of things that we need to worry
about because they don't seem to be
adjusted or retracted to think that our
most salient in the social environment
and they're thinking about others also
is quite reduced well just to show to
you that we did not necessarily concoct
this before coming to this class our
colleague Robert Schultz was here the
Child Study Center years ago provided us
with the summary of what or some areas
of the social brain as it were they seem
to be involved in those kinds of things
that we do so effortlessly
and when Kevin and Jamie talk about
their working near imaging and
electrophysiology we're gonna see more
about death mapping but just to give you
a little example here of the work that
Bob Schultz did here for example
individuals with autism are not
necessarily paying attention to others
faces so how did the process in their
brain so they go into the magnet in the
magnetic resonance imaging machine and
they are presented with those kinds of
stimuli so here are two faces and they
need to press same or different same or
different also objects same or different
and and there are some areas of the
brain that are particularly involved for
example in the recognition of faces one
of the errands in this network is the
fusiform gyrus which is seen here from
underneath the brain and here if there
is a coronal slice and this is already
an fMRI picture and you see the fusiform
gyrus on both sides and what this work
showed is very briefly is that worse
we've typically developing individuals
that particular area of the brain is
very involved not so with individuals of
autism and the interesting thing is that
after that work appeared people start
having theories about the possibility
that autism was caused by something
structurally wrong with the fusiform
gyrus until somebody who was working
with Bob Schultz he's now a physician
David Gregory did this work with a young
man whose life was really a digimon he
was in love with digimon figures and so
that's what he loved
talking about and when they conducted
this a single case study of of this
social brain network they found out that
for that young man faces did not
activate that particular structure
object certainly did not but when he was
placed in front of Digimon creatures my
goodness his fusiform gyrus was lighting
up like a Christmas tree which basically
tells us about the thing - that cannot
describe that this is a
neurodevelopmental disorder that
particular structure was as it were
hijacked by his love for Digimon
so there was not something structurally
wrong with it but he became specialized
in something other than people now a few
more of those illustrations when I
mentioned that there is tremendous
heterogeneity in intellectual function
videos of autism it really covers the
entire key spectrum but about fifty to
sixty percent of individuals of autism
have mental retardation have
intellectual disabilities and what is
really interesting about individuals of
autism is that are almost by definition
they have tremendous tremendous
variability in their IQ profile so that
some things they can do very very well
whereas other things they have a
tremendous amount of difficulty with and
that kind of a scatter creates true
puzzlement for anybody who is interested
in the brain probably the best
illustration comes from the work with
individuals who are servants now what
does that mean classically the the
concept of of Cervantes advance syndrome
comes from the observation that there
are individuals particularly individuals
of autism who can be intellectually
disabled but have an area of a special
skill something that they do much better
than anything else in many different
ways this is like an island of ability
surrounded by a sea of disability what
kinds of things do we see this is an
example from from a book on this on this
little girl Naevia and she liked to draw
and these are the kinds of drawings of
birds that nadia made which was about
four or five years of age and here you
see drawings a bird by some pretty
pretty good artist typically-developing
eight-year-old now she also drew horses
so this is a horse that nadia drew and
here's just for comparison why the
typically developing child a little
older we draw now she didn't draw one
horse she draw boxfuls are of horses she
draw many many many many many many
hundreds like those and yet at the time
that she was making those drawings she
was no furball she couldn't speak
that this is a Stephen Wiltshire and he
has a wonderful website that's you you
probably should check it out but Stephen
Wiltshire is a man from England
who also at the time that he started
making some some some drawings he was a
person who was was quite disabled and
yet he would produce those kinds of
drawings from memory at times from
observation and there are extraordinary
pictures in fact um if you know London
well you can recognize exactly what
those places are now some of the some of
the the sketches that the Stephen did
however we're not up of the same quality
like for example this sketch about a
very famous building in London now the
reason why I brought this picture here
is because if you could see it in great
detail you see a little detail on the
side and on this side there is a sign
and that sign says temporary road
surface the day he came to draw that
building they were fixing the road and
lo and behold his picture of of that
important building has that sign so what
was happening is that Stephen was
basically taking whatever he was seeing
and bring it onto canvas it was not
necessarily that he was working towards
this vision of what this building was
supposed to look forever and ever
it would be a little bit like visiting
the Louvre and taking a look at Mona
Lisa and finding out that the day that
Leonardo da Vinci was making his Madonna
there was somebody fixing the toilet and
so you would have Mona Lisa and the guy
fixing the toilet now he did not include
that he did not include that obviously
because he had a specific way that he
wanted people to see and appreciate that
picture and this is something that
certainly at the time that Steven was
producing this work it was not something
that was at the forefront of his mind
now just to take those kinds of extreme
examples and make it basically an
illustration of the learning style of
many individuals of autism this is
another illustration of a person that I
worked with many years ago who's our
drawing reflects his interest in
escalators and the subway system in
London and you see a lot of numbers here
and that's because he was also
interested in the calendar but there is
something very special about this that
you
not going to see enjoys of typically
developing children something that was
in fact invented or discovered as it
were in the Renaissance and that's
perspective so it's almost like he is
rendering on paper exactly what he seen
and this is a very as you where a very
poor drawing all together but there is
also something special about it do you
see that the man is behind at that door
now when typically developing children
are drawing things and they want to draw
somebody in the house they have the body
in that they have the clothes and then
they have and you see a lot of in a way
overlaps that you see in lines it's
because they are drawing from the minds
they are drawing from their concepts not
necessarily rendering what they are
seeing on the paper which basically
takes me to this example imagine if you
can for a second that you don't
recognize what this picture is but you
are basically taking each one of those
lines and moving on
following this grid you end up with
exactly the same picture but it's
impossible for you not to think about
what it is now that's because you go
from holes to parts many dividuals of
autism go from parts to holes and as
they do so they may not necessarily see
by the picture is so this is a little
test for you and this test is just to
show to you that you are holistic beings
okay are you ready
one and it's also test of wakefulness
this is critical for me one two and
three what did you see
you saw a computer actually you saw some
of these you saw some of these so
crackers and cookies yes you did see a
computer but that's because the
immediate thing that you see is a whole
is a gist and everything we do in life
we do that first maybe some people did
not so in many different ways that
summarizes to us a style that impacts on
everything that individuals of autism
have engaged with they tend to be very
much going from parts from parts to
holes and sometimes they miss the whole
the gist the the the context by focusing
on too many of those parts they don't
bring those fragments of experience into
one single coherent idea and yet other
people of course are whole two parts
they tend to be route and associative
whereas most of the things that we need
to do particularly in social life it's
it's it's integrative and conceptual I
not only listen to you but I listen to
what other people say and I look at your
faces and I look at your gestures and I
bring it all together in order to get
counts at the context in order to
understand what actually you mean and
because you are people who say things
that you don't mean and you mean things
that you don't say unless I pay
attention to this entire picture I will
miss I'll be overly literal I will be
too much obsessed with single aspects of
things that you do or say and I'll be
wrong most of the time because
intentionality is something that is
conveyed by by an attitude by something
that we do as a whole not necessarily by
a single word so this is one thing and
yet the individuals of autism learn a
great deal about the world
they tend to learn a tremendous amount
almost like because they learn about the
word explicitly as if they are reading
some kind of a narrative when in fact
most people they learn about the world
by experiencing it from the very very
very first months of life
babies not only are capable of taking
attention and moving elsewhere to get
things in the world they are sharing
experiences of others they can learn
through the actions of others
particularly towards things that they
never they never learn about before and
is this learning through others which is
a tremendous shortcut to learning about
the world that is in fact block or
severely attenuated in individuals with
with autism which in some cases leads to
this kind of phenomena as some of you
have seen higher function individuals
we've autism sometimes Asperger syndrome
whose whose main thing in life seems to
be one thing that they love to talk a
great deal about he seems like all of
their mental and their emotional energy
is focused on a particular aspect of the
world and sometimes a very unusual
aspect of the world about which they
learn a tremendous deal
what brought what what what happens is
that this causes the problem is because
you truly monopolizes they're learning
in monopolizes their thinking and in in
many different ways that's what they
want to talk about and sometimes you are
discussing something with somebody that
you need viewing and all that you're
hearing about is their subject of
circumscribed interest many different
ways
disrupts the entire process of the
conversation and years ago dr. volper
and I were seeing a particular child and
I asked the child to make a drawing of
himself like a good psychologist make a
drawing of yourself let's call him
charlie and this is the drawing that he
made now see if you have a guess what is
that well my friends not in a million
years this is in fact the coast of
California and this is Catalina Island
and this is here a tsunami wave and for
the next 30 minutes we talk about plate
tectonics which is something that he
really was interested in at a time and
yet what we wanted to learn about was
about him charlie
now this is also one of the most the
most popular circumscribe interest that
we learn about whatwhat is this
oh come on it's the Titanic and many of
our children they are capable of
reciting the names of everybody who
wasn't a Titanic how many people they
were there from what countries they came
from and every single possible is a
Taric detail about the Titanic and it's
interesting that some of those thoughts
can torture the monopolies of thinking
um remember for example one exaggeration
which I was giving a workshop in a in
the school district and as I was giving
this example a lady raised her hand and
she said oh now I understand something
that happened in my class what I do is
that I carry out the I the the movie
workshop in my school and so other kids
come in and they need to select one
movie and that movie becomes their
project and they need to come up with a
trailer something that is going to be
presented to the other kids and this
child wanted to arm to see the movie
Titanic you remember the Titanic it was
very romantic and also two relationships
I thought would be a good idea great
when this child came to present his work
there were about 20-30 scenes of the
movie scene number one the Titanic scene
number two a narrow view of the Titanic
see number three the propellers of the
Titanic see number four you could see
the entire trailer without
necessarily experiencing anything that
you might have experience with what were
the names of they'll not do something
and indicate something else but he was
basically reconstructing the world in
his image he was reconstructing the
world in terms of what was important to
him and that from a clinician standpoint
from a social neuroscientist spender
standpoint this this is what is most
exciting about working individuals of
autism it's not that they not they don't
learn about the world they learn a great
deal but the way they reconstruct the
world is quite different and it's
fascinating to enter that world
now this circumscribe interest is
something that creates a tremendous
amount of stability in their lives that
you people you seem to change all the
time
it's very difficult for me to have a
sense of how you're gonna feel tomorrow
because you change all the time
facts do not and if I know something
like the first President of the United
States that was George Washington
yesterday it is today and it's going to
be tomorrow in many different ways those
facts become an anchor for my
understanding of the world and for my
learning about people what is truly
interesting about those two is that they
tried many of folks try to understand
people in terms of their circumscribed
interest like typically developing
children when they are for example
playing with trains there is mommy
trainers they be trained they
anthropomorphize those objects in fact
we all want for more face objects the
Greeks did that when they're looking at
stars and they're giving all this
wonderful names to constellations when
people can't get a car started they
might stay baby you can do it you can do
it as they are talking with their own
cars
we untrim face people all the time for
many of our folks in do the other way
around for example I remember a child
who is very very interested in trains he
had maybe 150 different words to to
describe trains of different kinds and
attributes and those were the kinds of
words that he tried to use in order to
understand others and of course that
doesn't work very well on another
individual who was extremely interested
in how to brake equations but was very
puzzled about people like you
so he would assign a ladder to one
emotion that you have would create an
algebraic equation and then try to solve
it in order to
more insight into your feelings than
your intentions and so forth so how how
alienated is one need to be from an
intuitive sense of self and others in
order to use this kind of prosthesis so
those are the kinds of issues that we
focus in our world and so something like
this it helps them cope with fear and
with social confusion with
unpredictability with novelty of course
he has a negative impact we remember a
nine year old whose main love in life
was washers and dryers now he not only
that he talks about washers and dryers
at the time he talks to his peers about
washers and dryers how many friends do
you believe he has in his school well
not many right so that creates obviously
a great great great problem can we use
this on positive yes we can and if we
want to teach for example math maybe
this is what we need to do there were
1858 people in the Titanic
there were 24 life-saving boat a boat in
the Titanic how many people are gonna
die in the Titanic so many different
ways you're capitalizing on the strength
in order to teach something to the child
that she wouldn't know otherwise sure
this can happen Asperger doctorís barely
in fact thought that all of his patients
will do very well in the future because
he thought that all of them would be
scientists because they all had those
kind of circumscribed interests well
that transition is not so easy we
remember for example one child who was
very interested in electronics
so he wanted to learn everything about
it and he built radius of cardboard in
many different ways he created his own
vocabulary about electronics and built
his own things that had the semblance of
electronics but they were not
electronics in order for us to push this
child in the direction of something that
is going to be a vocation there is a lot
of work that needs to happen and those
are the kinds of examples that we see
from things such as snake school the
sacks the child was very interested for
example in deep fat fryers who would
walk into the restaurant and the first
thing you'll do is it run into that a
kitchen in order to engage they cook
about the president comes out the
different the Fed fryers we remember
this child who came here and he spoke in
such a way that it seemed like we had
basically plucked him from 14 or 15th
century Verona now he was very bright
that he could reach Shakespeare he was
not bright enough to realize that if he
spoke in that in that kind of a language
that his peers would not find it very
amusing or individuals who know
everything about TVs and in TV and radio
stations Digimon and all of those kinds
of examples now one thing that we've
learned over the years is that from any
of those individuals what happened is a
very dangerous conference on the eye on
the one hand they are totally absorbed
by some of those of those subjects and
yet they have no sense of common sense
and many individuals as they grow into
adulthood they don't have those many
opportunities to interact if people out
there but they are very capable of using
their computers and as they're using
their computers they're doing all sorts
of things that can get them into into
into trouble more about that when we
talk about transitioning into into
adulthood and and yet if there was one
thing that we wanted to communicate to
you today is that um in order for us to
be effective clinicians in order for us
to learn about autism we really need to
leave some of the some of the common
sense view of the world that we all have
home so that we can truly step into
their shoes and experience the world
through their eyes into their hearts and
we should not take any of those things
that we talked about here lightly
because they might assume sometimes
amusing to you but they are really quite
important for our patients for example
there was one child who came here and he
was very depressed and the loving life
for that boy was cool two sacks
everything he knew everything about
cul-de-sacs
and he turned up that he lived in a
cul-de-sac and the reason for him being
so depressed is because now they were
opening his street and he no longer
would live in the cul-de-sac and so
he'll be a little bit like basically
pulling the rug from under the structure
of his personality basically the
integrity of his entire mental structure
about self was going to come tumbling
down because he no longer would be
somebody who live in a cul-de-sac and
remember what I've mentioned before when
sometimes we talk about the possibility
that somebody is actually creating
algebraic equation to understand the
feelings of others this might sound
amusing and funny and yet this was a
reality of one man who came here and
told us left if he ever found out that
he would never have a girlfriend he
would kill himself and so of course we
are very alarmed by the by the suicidal
thought but most importantly we're very
curious as to how in the world was he
going to find out that he will never
have a girlfriend and then he came up
with those equations and the answer here
was that one day he would wake up in the
morning and he would have solved that
equation you'll be QED I will never have
a girlfriend and then he would be truly
in danger so this is the kind of mental
shift that you all need to do in order
to for us to talk about Social
Development the social mind and the
social brain in autism there are going
to be a lot of reading materials in the
web and many of the things that doctor
volkmar and myself talked about today
and many of our colleagues are going to
be discussing in great detail the next
two weeks are gonna be there
so I hope you don't worry today that you
did not write every single note and that
you'll be able to get back to that as
December progresses now a little bit of
context for this course I'm I'm the
director of the autism program here the
Child Study Center which is something
that goes back over 50 years
and dr. volkmar has been a central
figure in that program since the early
eighties before us dr. Donald Cohen and
before us in the 50s as you heard before
some of the some of the pioneers in this
field were were here working with
individuals with autism and their
families our program has a has four
missions the first one is that we
provide clinical services we see many
many many individuals for four clinical
evaluations for treatment and we also
consult to the people who will serve
them and provide therapies and this
a key aspect of what we do we're also a
research program and our research
program really ranges from anything from
gene finding through access to services
in the community speech language
pathology communication
electrophysiology the social brain the
social mind you name it but this is a
key aspect of what we do we want to
advance knowledge about this field we
also a training program and that's what
we're doing
we are trying to access yo college
students because at that time of your
life you're still making up your minds
as to what you want to do in the future
and interesting enough some of the most
promising recruits in our program have
actually come from this class over the
years so you be careful because if you
join this course we may change your your
professional life and finally we're also
an advocacy program which means that we
work very closely with parent support
organizations locally regionally
internationally also with governmental
agencies this is critical for us we wear
all of those hats and the reason for
that is that in this field unless we
synergize we may get a very partial view
of what this condition is about and in
many different ways the hub of our
program consider continue to be our
clinical services we are we are actually
pretty proud that some of our very best
research hypotheses have come from the
observations that we have made in our
play rooms and in our clinical interview
rooms and in so doing we hope to be
close to phenomena that really matters
to those individuals and to their
families as well as to translate our
scientific findings into things that are
going to be helpful not only in our
clinics but also in the classrooms not
only in Connecticut but everywhere